Greg's leftovers hmm
[Music]
time once again for leftovers which has
just been voted TV's third most popular
segment in all of Lafia
didn't even know they had television
there and I'm very happy might go over
there
I don't know do whatever you do in
Latvia it's where I read the jokes that
we didn't use this week as always it's
my first time reading these so here we
go oh God help me President Biden
visited a Baskin Robbins this week
making history as the first customer to
get a brain freeze before eating the ice
cream
that's cheaper
perfect
interestingly Joe has been in politics
so long when he was first elected Baskin
Robbins only had two flavors
gonna chop that one off
school officials and parents were
outraged when a stripper appeared during
an event at a Michigan High School
although students weren't present
officials were unsure if the stripper
should be banned from the premises or
brought back for career day
laughs
meanwhile the school board says they
don't condone such a sexualized
performance at a high school requesting
to keep the stripper show where it
belongs in elementary schools
Late Late Show host James Corden was
banned from a Swanky Manhattan Eatery
it's Gordon's second restaurant band
since his carpool karaoke got stuck in
the drive-through at Taco Bell
yeah researchers at Boston University
are being criticized for creating a new
strain of covid-19 that killed 80
percent of the test mice
set a spokesperson for the mice
honey
huh that's what you call an audible that
was better than the punch line that
wasn't in the prompter vice president
Kamala Harris has hired an unprecedented
third head speechwriter but she says
she's not worried this time around
because she found someone with a perfect
grasp of the English language
U.S Senate hopeful John fetterman says
he's almost fully recovered from the
stroke he suffered back in May fetterman
then thanked his wife and parents who
never wavered in their payment of his
allowance
he also credited his quick recovery to
apple cider vinegar and Coffee Bean
supplements he saw on The Dr Oz Show
funny that's good a Texas landlady says
she can't rent out her property a 19th
century brothel because it's haunted by
horny ghosts
that's nothing I've been having sex with
a ghost for 50 years said the First Lady
[Applause]
a new study finds NHL players are
overwhelmingly white meanwhile the
league mentioned their previous
initiative to hire black Zamboni drivers
but they kept getting pulled over by the
cops
funny because it's true we think last
week in Italy a man played the saxophone
while undergoing a nine hour brain
surgery to remove a tumor doctors
carefully monitored him and when they
enjoyed attuned they threw a dollar in
his skull
okay
good one Joy Behar blasted voters during
an episode of The View stating their
focus on the economy is sad and
depressing instead she recommended
voters do what she does in difficult
times focus on Donuts
too easy finally this week President
Biden erroneously promoted a
non-existent tax credit for coffee
machines in his defense a hot brown
liquid was on his mind
and in his pants
[Applause]
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else